hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the ghost pepper of
commitment I have something incredibly
important that I'm going to be telling
you today that affects the entirety of
my channel but before I get started I
have to eat this ghost pepper
[Music]
okay okay
I'm gonna be going to one video a day
you've already seen the results of this
over the past week that I've been doing
it because
because
because I I over the past week I've been
uploading every day at the exact same
time with one video and the videos have
been longer than they have before Oh
God
the videos have been longer than they
have before because I've been playing
whole games in a single video it's
because I've
been
the
the overhead breaking up the part of the
video is having of the not in in 15 or
30 minutes Parts is an old hey over
everyone you couldn't have
videos be longer than a certain amount
of time in a certain amount of time so I
want to play full games in certain
videos I want to compact a bunch of
games into certain videos and the
response has been great so far because
you're gonna have to
you guys seem to have loved it and
that's super awesome thank you guys so
much for understanding and it's been
great support and also
I'll be uploading at exactly 11 A.M
Pacific Standard time every single day
every single day and I don't want to
break the
[Music]
there'll be more gaming content than
ever before because there's gonna be
both in every video also there'll be
more live action challenges cool videos
look of course and I'll be doing
there'll be more cool stuff that I'll be
doing like the video where I was in a
hanging a safety harness for hardest
than it was before challenges Etc
more live-action Goose it'll be great
and I am committing to this 100 I'm not
gonna lie about this what I'm committing
to this 100 oh it's better everywhere
I'm committing this to 100 because if I
don't upload every single day at the
exact same time if I miss an upload for
any single reason the reason this is
called ghost pepper of commitment is
because
if I don't if I don't I have to eat
another ghost pepper live wherever I am
on live stream wherever I am if I miss a
video I have to eat another ghost pepper
and it doesn't matter
I'm starting so much
it doesn't matter where I am live I will
eat a ghost pepper on camera for you
guys as punishment and then I will
resume the schedule every single day
that I miss if I miss more than one day
no matter where I am and that's all I
got it
foreign
faces
[Music]
worn out please pain is only in the mind
everything is really good
I'm really happy
with the way I want to make videos and I
want to make better content for you guys
more better
and this change is not something that
comes easy all around me are familiar
it just get worse it just gets worse
it just gets worse
I just want to make better confidence
for you is this
is better content
is it but this is why I'm committed to
this I will stick to this schedule tell
your friends tell everybody I'm back I'm
better than ever before and I'm gonna
make so many cool videos in the future
not all of them are gonna be as stupid
to do this some might even be stupider
but you could guarantee
that there's not going to be a single
boring video on my channel so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]